hey that great idea that you've been
sitting on well it's time to turn that
into a reality and squarespace is there
to help you out they make it easier than
ever to launch your passion project
whether you want to showcase all that
work you've been doing or sell all those
products you've been making
they have beautiful templates and the
ability to customize just about anything
so you can easily make a beautiful
website
all by yourself but if you get stuck
squarespaces 24
7 award-winning customer support is
there to help so head to squarespace.com
grace for a free trial and when you're
ready to launch use the offer code grace
to save 10 off your first purchase of a
website or domain
hello and welcome to another episode of
not too deep i'm your host
grace helbig very very exciting episode
ahead we have mother palestinian muslim
american
activist organizer incredible human
being author i've
there's so many things about this woman
linda sarsour is here today and i
uh i'm so excited on your behalf that
you get to listen to this episode
we talk about her 20-plus year history
of getting into the world of activism
and organizing
as a resident from brooklyn with
immigrant parents her
story is incredible which you can also
read more in depthly in her new memoir
we are not here to be bystanders
bystanders if i could talk sorry i used
up all my good talking in this
interview with her uh she explains the
world of organizing in a way that makes
sense to someone like me who doesn't
really know from the outside
she also has profound and prolific and
promising advice for people that are
interested
in getting involved but don't know how
interested in
how to navigate difficult conversations
how to help in the georgia runoff
elections
and she's just all around a lovely
lovely human being
and i hope you get inspired the way that
i did after this conversation i just
can't say enough good things so i'll
shut up and let you listen already
enjoy this episode of not too deep with
linda sarsour
[Music]
linda thank you so much for being here
i'm very very excited and i'm eager to
learn
many many things and i can't believe
that you had a break in your schedule to
make time for us so thank you so much
thank you so much for having me of
course now for people that don't
know you or what you're about can you
give us a little bit of back story
uh as to how you got where you are today
it's um your memoir will have it all in
there for people but if you can give us
kind of a brief overview that'd be
awesome
absolutely um really uh grace nothing
extraordinary about me
i am adorable that's not true
palestinian immigrants i'm born and
raised in brooklyn which is a very
important part of my identity
i have been an organizer and an activist
since the immediate aftermath of the
horrific attacks of 9 11.
i immediately started organizing uh
translation services amongst muslim
americans and muslim immigrants that
were
being directly impacted in the aftermath
and i've been a
civil rights activist i organized across
the country i was one of the
co-founders of the women's march on
washington back in 2017
and i'm also alongside tamika mallory my
sister
one of the co-founders of until freedom
who have been uh taking residency in
louisville kentucky to work on behalf of
the family of briana taylor who as many
of you know how was murdered at the
hands of the louisville metro police
department
so that's who i am and i'm an author i'm
uh you know
doing my thing feeling like right you're
doing
so many incredible things um and at a
time that it is it's so
wildly necessary i think one of my
first questions is i'm curious about
what
goes into organizing because we see
people on the streets we see people
making petitions making
rallies all these different things but
it's such a more complicated thing than
what i as a bystander see
so how do you describe the world of
organizing
absolutely i wouldn't call you a
bystander grace i think what you're
doing is playing your role like
everybody's supposed to play their role
giving platform to people who do this
work
organizing is um deeper than just seeing
people protesting in the street or going
out to a march
which is part of organizing but really
fundamentally what organizing is is
being able to influence to train people
to get people to understand
what skills do you bring to the table
and how can we leverage your skills for
the goodness of the community the
neighborhood the society the nation that
you live in and so organizing requires a
lot of
skills building capacity building it's
strategy
it's you know you have to decide okay
what is the thing you're trying to
change here and who has the power over
changing that thing and building a
campaign around that so it requires a
lot of
thoughtfulness thinking a lot of
strategizing a lot of building a lot of
relationship building a lot of
collaboration coalitions uh and it so it
takes a lot of work on
it for some of us it's become our
full-time job yeah for something to
like this it seems like it could be this
thing that you kind of do in the
background of your normal life and for
it to take the forefront
of your life how did was that a
conscious
like click for you or did you kind of
get you
obviously have lived in justices have
seen injustices
and decided to speak up so was this an
organic sort of move for you or did you
decide like this is what i'm doing
actually for me i was an aspiring high
school english teacher i was like
i did english literature and i minored
in secondary education and i watched
this movie with michelle pfeiffer back
in the 90s called dangerous minds and i
was like i'm going to be missing
near city schools and i'm going to
inspire these young people of color and
that's really what i wanted to do
and of course after the horrific attacks
of 9 11 as a new yorker as you know it
was
devastated our city um you know over 3
000 people our fellow new yorkers
are perished in that attack but also
what happened immediately after that
is all levels of law enforcement
descended on the communities that i came
from and so what i witnessed in new york
is things that people don't believe
could happen in the united states
i saw like apartment buildings where law
enforcement would go in raid apartment
buildings bring men out into the street
lay them out on the sidewalk
their kids are watching from the windows
women are crying and
i was you know watching from my own
window and i'm like why is this
happening i mean these people live in
brooklyn they have
absolutely nothing to do with this
horrific thing that just happened that
also
scared them too yeah and so then what my
immediate um
you know inclination was i spoke fluent
arabic which was a language that many
people my community spoken was their
first language
became a translator and so i started
going to detention centers across the
northeast helping women
track down their loved ones um who are
unfortunately
and so from there is where it clicked
for me um i had i had two kids at that
time and i remember just being in
detention centers where sometimes i
wouldn't be able to go inside so i would
sit in the waiting area with little
children like
six-year-olds whose mothers were inside
talking to their fathers and
really saw my own kids in them and so i
clicked from you i was like look these
are my people and
um they can't fight for themselves
because they don't understand how the
system works they don't speak the
language and so since that time
till now i have been an organizer and
activist
trying to play my role in defending what
i believe to be the most marginalized
people
wow and you say you have kids how
do your kids see you today because not
only are you doing all these incredible
things but you're making time to be a
mother
at the same time which i i don't have
children i have a dog
but i can imagine that it is incredibly
difficult to balance
all of those things at the same time i
also have two cats so i'm a mom
um i have uh my children um grew up in
this work that i've done
over the last 20 years so my son right
now is 21 years old
i have a daughter who's going to be 20
years old and i have a daughter who's
16. and then
to experience my work on a very personal
level
sometimes i would have to be supporting
their friends families
um sometimes you know it's people in the
very community that we
live in our neighbors and so my children
are very
have a very worldly perspective you know
they're not detached from the work uh
that i do
and i know that they're proud of me and
one of the reasons why i wrote my memoir
was and people were like why are you
writing a memoir you're only
you know at the time when i started
writing it i was only like 38 years old
they were like you're 38
why do memoir when you're like 60. you
have a lot more things to do and what i
said to people was listen i don't know
how long i have
um on this earth i wanted to give my
children something to hold my
grandchildren my great-grandchildren
something that
told their story um that humanized them
and the communities that i came from
because as you know grace from watching
sometimes different elements of the
media
the communities that i come from are not
humanized you know we're only in the
context of war and conflict you know in
the context of terrorism
and people talk about us in those ways
and so i wanted to put out a story that
was a humanizing story of a mother from
brooklyn you know of a woman who had
children of someone who went to public
school
and i'm a daughter of immigrants which
many people in america are so there's a
lot of things to kind of connect with me
about
um yeah so my kids you know have had a
rough couple of years you know watching
their mom go through a lot of difficult
moments but
i'm pretty sure that they're proud of
you i think they have to be i mean
it's incredible the work you do and to
be so open with them
and exposing them in a way that lets
them see things and shape their own
opinions and their
ideas of how they want to exist in the
world and help others
i think it's hugely important i'm also
curious because you released your memoir
this year and it's been an
incredibly complicated year in so many
ways
and putting your story out there by
default is just hugely
impactful and helpful for communities
like you said that don't get to see
themselves or hear stories related to
them
but at the same time promoting yourself
in a book must have been a little bit
uh conflicted at times what was that
like for you
i am very fortunate to come from a
community that
loves me and supports me across the
country so i didn't really i haven't
really done a lot of promotion on my own
book others have done it
yeah you've been very humble about it it
feels like it's flied under the radar
but it's also there yeah like it's not
my it's not who i
am and so i've been very fortunate to
have a lot of you know muslim
organizations that have you know bought
them for their schools and
you know and a lot of muslim american
organizations who give out my book like
as gifts for
for donors a lot of my friends who are
professors around the country who have
taken on my book as required reading for
their classes
um you know my book also came out in the
middle of a global pandemic and i had
a very robust um uh
you know tour that didn't quite go the
way that it
should have went because of the kovid
and i was able to do many wonderful
you know virtual events but i'm an
organizer and one of the things even
that was really hilarious about my
my my tour was you know i had this whole
thing about how i was going to register
voters
at all of my events and that i was sure
i was gonna and
my publisher was like well i get what
you're trying to do here but
you just sit on a chair and just tell us
about your life like why did you
organize everything and so i still was
able to
um you know during quarantine do virtual
virtual events and then i've done some
actually in some areas some
smaller kind of you know of course
because of kovid uh and and my book has
reached i went to louisville kentucky as
you know i lived there for
a couple of months and i'm actually
going back there again after the january
run-offs in georgia
and i got there and people had my book
like i went to the bookstore
i was living very close to a bookstore
called carmichael's in louisville
kentucky i happened to walk into a
random small
kind of mom-and-shop bookstore and my
book was right there like when i walked
in it was like very prominently
placed so it's been beautiful to just
walk into bookstores
um and to see people tag me on social
media that they got my book
they read my book so i'm i'm humbled by
the support that i've received
that's so cool um i'm really curious
because
a lot of people i think have uh finally
opened their eyes this year to a lot of
things that have
they've maybe conveniently closed them
to for years and years
and there's a lot of divisiveness in
politics and in culture
and the movement and the organizing that
you do
what do you find is the biggest
misconception for people
about what you're doing because i think
a lot of people are so quick to assume
certain things
write off an entire movement or a group
of people without knowing the full
context of things
absolutely i mean i have been a very
controversial figure in the movements
that i've been a part of just in general
and because i'm a muslim woman i'm
palestinian there's a lot of parts of my
identity that are deemed very
controversial and also there are things
that i believe that a lot of people
don't believe which is fine
i think the deception is that the
movements we're a part of are somehow
we're all brainwashed and we all believe
the same things and we don't
even in this groups that i organize with
very on a very like small circle level
there are debates that we have about
issues i mean i remember
debate that came up for us during the
women's march where women
you know was were really like upset and
said
well what if we're pro-life does that
mean we're not part of your movement and
i said listen we never said we were a
pro-abortion movement we are a
pro-choice movement so if you are one
that chooses your faith and
chooses not to have an abortion and
another woman has a different life
circumstance and she chooses to go
another way
women are respected in all of their
agency and so the thing that i hope
people understand about movement work is
that unity is not uniformity there is
really
not a lot of agreement on everything in
the movement i mean for example you know
i work in the criminal justice reform
space people in our movements are
abolitionists they believe in this idea
that
we should abolish the police and we
should abolish prisons right
and you know i'm on the pathway to
abolition but there are other people who
want to do criminal justice reform they
do not absolutely believe that we could
live in a world without police
or without prisons and so the question
is how do those people organize together
and so
i want to welcome people into space and
to say listen you don't have to come to
a space and be like well in order for me
to come and be an organizer and actors i
have to agree with everything that
people say
it's not going to work because you know
the race we don't agree with half the
people in our family about things
yeah everyone in a
space and people we don't even know or
at least never like you know built deep
relationships with so that's the big
misconception
yeah that are agree on everything and
it's just not gonna work and i think
yeah that makes so much sense um and i
think one of the things
that i've noticed is people are
attempting to have difficult
conversations that they
perhaps haven't had before with
significant others with family members
with complete strangers do you
have and you've been doing this for
years and years and years so a lot of
people are very late to your
uh your ship on this do you have any
tips for people that are
curious and possibly a little
overwhelmed at the idea of starting a
difficult conversation with someone
absolutely i mean i actually do this
training around the
country um i say to people you have you
got to meet people where they're at and
there's approaches as you see on social
media is a cesspool
um and it could be a very productive
place where you learn new things you
meet new people i get to follow people
that i may not
ever have had you know personal
interaction with and learn from them
but it's also a very judgmental place
and in order to have the
courageous conversation is you got to
understand why people believe the things
that they believe
what what got them to the point of
believing those things you know
there have been an experience with them
they may have learned that learn those
things from their grandparents or from
their parents and be taking people on a
journey from point a to point b
and what we have in this culture right
now is you know grace is cancelled
culture
grace goes online says something that it
either is misinterpreted
or immediately uh grace is cancelled
because grace is wrong about something
instead of saying to grace
hey you said something that you know
really hurt me or i was offended by then
here's why i'm offended and grace can
say wait a minute that is not what i
meant or you know what you just taught
me something new
i didn't know that and so we don't
really we live in a society where we
don't give people chances
and as someone who comes out of the
justice reform movement
i believe in second and third and fourth
chances i don't believe people are to be
condemned
forever or off of mistakes that they
have made and so
i want i i tell people all the time even
if it's your grandfather i mean like i
say to people all the time if i don't
agree with someone in my family i still
love them
like that's just what it is you just
gotta take people on a journey and so i
come from a community where you know we
have a lot of issues like in other
communities patriarchy you know
having to unlearn sometimes centuries of
things
have gone passed on from generation and
generation so i can't just say to
someone you are
wrong and then you have no potential of
getting better
and just dismiss those people forever i
don't believe in that so i tell people
don't impose your your opinions on
people take them on a journey explain to
them why you believe what you believe
you know
ask them why they believe what they
believe and then together you can take
them to a better place and it's happened
i've seen it happen across the country
it's transformational
just really where they're at yeah it
seems like if you
boil it down to more of like a gentle
curiosity
that can get you to like a starting
point to be able to
unpack and unravel like you said
potentially
centuries of uh unconscious conditioning
that people have had people will ask me
like why do you wear that
but i'm not offended in fact actually
happy when people ask me these things
that i'm sure they've been walking
around with and wondering all these
years about why do
people do this why do you look like that
why you know why do you do these certain
things and i want people to ask me those
questions i mean if you're
if someone's listening to your show and
there's a question that's been boiling
for you about
muslims or about you know refugees about
muslim immigrant communities about
anything
i want to answer your question no
question for me stupid and i'm not
judge you because you are you are at
least taking the point the the the step
of asking a question
versus just making judgment or off of
something that you may not understand
i think that's great because there is
you
you are a very gently aggressive
personality and i mean then a great way
that you have a very welcoming sense to
you
and also a no [ __ ] meter a bit which
is great
i know it shows that it's great and it's
so it's a wonderful balance
uh which is what i'm curious because i
was you know going through all of your
social media and everything
and you posted some videos i guess there
were like live
streams of like you know the night of
the election and you had
just such a wonderful calm encouragement
of keeping people from going from like a
to z getting completely overwhelmed with
you know initial
uh numbers and polls and percentages and
all of that
what for you over the last you know few
weeks has been
some of the most more encouraging things
that you've seen
come out of this election and in all of
its chaos
oh i've had so many moments grace i mean
i've worked in six states over the last
few weeks and just seeing like
the early voting lines i saw young
people that were voting for the first
time i i met new immigrants who had just
became u.s citizens who are also
voting for the first time i saw mom
grandma great grandma and granddaughter
and great granddaughter
all together like at the polls you know
i've i've had a lot of inspiring moments
i've watched people defend each other at
polls where
a poll worker will say you can't vote
here because of whatever reason you know
there was
some voter suppression that was
happening and watching other voters say
no but she's my neighbor she gets to
vote here and people kind of stand up
for one another
it was inspiring and it was i'm also
inspiring to talk to people that
were i mean i didn't ask anybody on the
polls where they they were voting for i
was just happy you were there to vote
yeah just having conversations with
people
that eventually we find out you know
five minutes into a conversation that
they were not going to vote for the
people that i was voting for or the
person i was voting for and still having
that conversation so
the the election for me was always
encouraging just watching
um you know so many people go out to the
polls and even on the day of elections i
was in michigan
which was um a state that i've organized
also in for seven years it
has the largest muslim american voter
population in the country
and i was moved by my own people i went
to the dearborn city clerk's office
which is where first-time voters can
vote on the day of elections which is
very
you know which is a lot of progress to
be able to vote and vote on the same day
and the line was around the corner like
around and most of the people that were
on the line in dearborn were people that
were from my community they were arab
americans they were muslim americans and
i was just literally put we put up a
little dj stand had some music we were
giving out
snacks and water on the line because it
was so long and it was
great and i had a great time oh that's
beautiful okay we're gonna take a quick
break when we get back i have all kinds
of questions about social media so we'll
be right back with more not too deep
[Music]
it's time to turn your dream into a
reality with
you guessed it squarespace squarespace
makes it easier than ever to launch your
passion project
you want to start a new business you
want to showcase the work
that you've been working on publish the
content you've been contenting
sell the products you've been producing
or more squarespace is the tool for you
they've beautiful templates created by
world-class designers and the ability to
customize just about anything with a few
clicks
so you can easily make a beautiful
website all by yourself they also have a
powerful ecommerce functionality that
lets you sell anything online
and analytics that help you grow your
site in real time
and everything is optimized for mobile
right out of the box there's nothing to
patch or upgrade
ever buying domains is simple and you
can get all the help you need with their
24
7 award-winning customer support they
empower millions of people
designers lawyers artists gamers even
restaurants and gyms remember them
to help turn great ideas into something
real head to squarespace.com
grace for a free trial and when you're
ready to launch use the offer code grace
to save 10
off your first purchase of a website or
domain that's squarespace.com
grace offer code grace
all right let's talk about social media
because i'm sure in your years of doing
this
you started probably when there was no
social media there was no access to
people from the the comfort of your own
home how have you seen
that progression happen especially in
this last year i feel like it's been
more than ever a tool for people for
better or worse
in all avenues how have you seen it grow
i mean i started organizing in 2001 that
was like still aol.com
yeah i'm a generation of the beepers
like i
feel sometimes like when i organize in
college campuses and they're looking at
me i'm like i'm old
computers i mean social media didn't
start for me till about maybe 2005 or
2006.
and for me um you know social media is
really embraced how my
platform how i got a platform i mean
media again wasn't listening to voices
like mine you know i didn't have a
platform
you never seen muslim women in hijab on
cnn or msnbc and it's just
we were just not there we were like
totally non-existent and social media
came along and gave everybody a platform
and
you built your own content you told your
own stories and so
there's definitely for me been a lot of
positive that came out of social media
but there was also the negative i mean
when you're when you're tweeting when
you have like a hundred followers
talking or not even three followers
and you're just saying all this you know
i'm raunchy i'm from brooklyn you know
you
weren't here you may said something here
had this conversation you know how it is
people will go pull up something that
you said
you know 15 years ago or 14 years ago
and you know and
and it's out of the context of your work
and who you are
you know how it is you know it's just so
so that's been you know
um i think troubling for a lot of people
that are you know in the kind of same
position that i'm that i'm in
i think you know social media is a place
where you can't really have you know
nuanced conversation i mean i can't i
can't explain to you
the things that you want to know in 280
characters and mind you you got 280
characters like
you had to do 140 for a while yeah
yeah impossible yeah facebook you know
was a little bit more personalized i
think facebook has now moved into a more
broader space where you could have
followers if they're not your friends
and instagram
and things like that but for me and i
think movement people particularly black
and brown people that don't have a lot
of platforms social media really came in
and gave us
a way to speak to our community so a way
to the young people and generations in
our community and so
uh as much as i critique social media i
see it as a very helpful tool for
for voices like mine a hundred percent
and there's
i'm curious because i've struggled with
this a little bit this year and i
friends in the you know internet space
the the
idea of performative activism
on social media i think people get very
overwhelmed with the idea of wanting to
participate in some way
and um and a lot of people you know in
the cancer
cancel culture of it all are quick to
call people
out on disingenuous sort of engagement
in a cause or a movement
how if you have any tips for people that
want to get involved on social media but
also want to make sure that they're not
doing it
solely performatively absolutely i mean
for me as people see you know for my own
social media like i
there are people that are like social
media activists like they don't
they are not in the street they just
read about it and it's very unfortunate
and so that's why there is sometimes
resentment that comes you'll see
conflict on social media with people who
are
actually on the street i mean actually
organizing people actually
hustling and leaving our families and
going to other cities and then you see
other folks who are
sitting in the house and apparently they
have you know bylines in the new york
times and i'm like but you're not here
in the street like how do you know
what's happening in louisville kentucky
for example with brianna taylor when
you're not over here
so that's unfortunate but for regular
people ordinary people i think it is
important for you to use your social
media responsibly i mean one thing i
tell people all the time is you know
when you hear about us
a case you know being able to use your
facebook to say hey
do you know what happened to brianna
taylor um you know when you are out i
don't believe it's performative if you
go to a rally and you come back and post
a photo
saying here's how i felt here's why this
why i went to this rally or
here's you know the mo it's not just i
went to the rally right getting a little
more deeper in a space to share a story
about what moved you to go to that rally
because what might happen grace
someone else is going to be inspired by
that and maybe go with you to your next
rally
there is performative activism but i do
think it's the minority of activism i
think that
everyone needs to find their role
everybody has a place um
i remember at the women's march on
washington's in 2017 you know
we had no idea what was going to happen
we were like okay great 200
000 women were going to come to
washington dc and we thought that was
quite impressive
yeah when we got there the mpd was like
you said 200
000. and i said oh how many people are
here he was like about 1.2 million
people and he's like
that million extra and i said i don't
know what to tell you like
yeah what do you do at that point it's
kind of like this is cool
at the end of the at the end of like the
the
program i jumped off the stage we had
security detail because there was like
crazy people that were threatening us
that stuff and so i just kind of ran
away from security and i jumped off the
stage and i went into the crowd
i grace i've met people that never
marched
ever in their lives like that was the
first time they ever went to a march
i saw again grandma granddaughter grant
you know daughter
entire families people that were like oh
these ladies all live in my street like
a whole block
from like arkansas organized and came
all the women in that block
got on a bus from arkansas and came to
washington dc so
what i say to people you know the
women's march was an opportunity not
just to have a march because i've been
organizing marches for 20 years
it was about saying to someone you don't
have to be an activist and organizer to
stand up and say
i believe in something you know that i'm
worthy i'm worthy my daughter's worthy
my family is worthy
and that was a moment that really
inspired a lot of activism across the
country
so there were women who now were
starting women's march chapters they
were starting indivisible chapters they
were starting
other kinds of organizing things where
they were helping refugees doing refugee
resettlement where
you know they were do vote you know
registering voters on their street in
their own
they've never done that before they were
like you know a lot of them were like
i'm a housewife or
yeah a school teacher i'm a social
worker you know i work in tech
that's right and they even found their
role i mean the women's march my team at
the women's march national was about
45 women and they all came from you know
some of them were
yoga teachers in tech some people were
in branding and marketing
some women worked in like corporate
america and then there were other women
who were activists and organized and all
of a sudden we came
and women's march on washington happened
and it was until today
it is the largest protest in american
history i mean
yeah i i was part of the los angeles
march and seeing it was uh indescribable
that just the feeling of everyone there
and seeing the images from dc
were just so overwhelming
so profound and so like beautiful
uh in you know the underlying pain that
the whole reason the march is happening
and it's incredible and speaking of
women
you have obviously become an incredible
role model for women i
so many messages i got yesterday when i
asked for questions for you were just
like i don't have any questions
i just think she's wonderful and i i
can't get enough of what she's doing and
she's inspired me so much
how does that feel for you do you do you
think
about being a role model for women or is
that just kind of the byproduct of the
work you're doing normally
you know i never really thought about
that a lot for women in general but i
have thought about it many times for
women in my own community
especially little muslim girls in my
community so even when i wrote my memoir
i wanted a different photo on the front
of my book
and my editor was like no the photo is
going to be your face
and you and your powerful face and i was
like what did you
want on the book instead i actually had
a different photo of a rally that i
helped organize in washington dc that
had all these beautiful muslim women
that were like at the front of the line
and i wanted to just show because my
book wasn't really i mean it's about me
but it's not about
sure and my editor was like you are you
have to understand that
you who you are and how you show up in
the world is is is
something it's worth something and so
when a little girl walks into a
bookstore and sees your face on a book
like you have to understand that it's
not just about issues
and so for me i i really um am inspired
by when women who are not from my
community say that to me or
and it's important because you know even
i never really considered myself to be a
feminist it's not a word that i've ever
used before because i never really felt
like i would be included in that kind
of you know western feminist you know
kind of narrative that has happened over
the many years
and you know when i went to the women's
march on washington just to see you know
women there were
a million women that were cheering me on
here's this woman from brooklyn with a
hijab you know muslim woman a
palestinian woman
i've traveled the country grace i've
been to all white churches
um in in the middle of america i've been
to the south um
yeah i have been in you know spaces with
african americans
only latino communities only and little
girls from those communities will come
to me and say you are my role model
there's a book that
came out a few months ago also called
muslim
uh i want to say it's called muslim
women rise but it's
basically a children's book and like i'm
in the front of the book with ilhan and
some other muslim women and i remember
being at the park with my niece like
before quarantine happened
and this little girl runs a little white
girl runs up to me in the park
and she had her book bag and she puts a
book bag on the floor and i'm like
what's about to happen
yeah opens her book bag and then all of
a sudden pulls out this book and she's
like look this is you
on the book and i literally bawled my
eyes out like
i got chills literally she ran for her
book brown phone and i'm
literally looking around like this is a
curious moment
just opens her book bag and pulls out
this book and it's and she's like a
little white girl like literally blonde
black girl in the park
house and her mom bought her a book
about muslim women and i thought it was
the most
inspiring thing i literally went later
on and walked up to her mother and i was
like
i just want you to know like you are a
great mom like you are great
and her mom was like what happened i
said you're trying
to go to a book that she had in her book
and she's like oh my gosh she loves that
book
oh that's incredible listen this is
i feel humbled um to have people you
know look up to me
that's incredible i also love that even
your own memoir you still wanted it to
be about everyone else except for
yourself
you can't not it's not happening
i am curious because i think you know in
doing all these thinking about like how
the world works and why people
are the way they are and express
themselves the way they express
themselves
i wonder if a lot of it comes down to
just lack of
diversifying the way you um get your
news
the way you get your information and i
i've been guilty of you know
watching solely cnn or msnbc for
and then being you know persuaded by
solely the way they're they're
presenting their news do you have any
tips or thoughts on on diversifying the
way that you
you that people get their information
absolutely i think it's exactly what
you're saying grace like i watch
everything you know i want
people to also understand like my mom
you always laugh at me because i i'm not
gonna lie i watch fox news sometimes and
yeah no i put it on just to see how it's
being presented
you know i just want to know what other
information people are getting i know
how to have and handle conversations
that i'm going to have in the world um
you know i think for me
i feel like following human beings and
not just media sources is important you
know
storytelling for me is important so
reading memoirs
not just mine but of other people like
of indigenous people you know
memoirs of black women you know memoirs
of people who are from communities that
you are not from
yeah from those personal stories not
only will you learn something but you
will also connect you'll be like oh yeah
like when i wrote my book like
a lot of people went to public school
you know a lot of people are children of
immigrants a lot of people remember the
brooklyn stoops that i sat
on with my family you know people were
connecting with me on such very simple
things that i was like talking about in
the book stories like for example in my
book you know
talking about the horrific attacks of 9
11 everybody remembers where they were
that day
right whether you were in la whether you
were in new york whether you were even
you know happened to be studying at
oxford in the uk like
everybody was somewhere and had
something to feel about that so we all
connected a lot of people said i
connected with you
you brought me back to that day and
where i was and how i was feeling
and so that's really um for me
like the the journey yeah yeah yeah now
activism and all of this aside because
there is
and you know best there there is a
burnout that can happen
um when you are go go go put it all out
there and it's a very emotionally
charged
work environment that you're in what do
you do to relax
do you are there things that you watch
what are guilty pleasures what are
hobbies i know you barely have time but
if you do
ever what happens i'm not gonna lie to
you i do
i have a nice manicure oh i love it
never catch me in the street without
that's without a nice manicure
my thing my little personal thing i also
you know i
uh there's this uh um a soap opera kind
of
thing that's on netflix it's actually a
turkish soap opera that
over half the world population has
watched
what is it called called earth and it's
uh you know
it's a it's like you know based in like
medieval times or like you know
during like the crusades anyway it's a
very like love story
and like you know war and conflict okay
it's very like you know engaging and
it's one of the things like i watch it
and for some reason i really feel like
i'm not in the world at all like i just
wanted
the world and so that's a guilty
pleasure that i found recently
uh particularly when we like when we
were really quarantined and it has like
400 episodes so it's not one of those
netflix series like
13 episodes per season but
and it's worth the time so you know that
soap opera is um
i'm a foodie so i still like food um
that's a guilty pleasure that i have and
eating really good food that's one thing
where i
tell people i'm i can be stingy on
everything else but when it comes to
food i'm not i want to eat
there's not a there is not a kind of
food that you can tell me about
probably that i do not like um really
the only thing i tell people is like i
just don't eat pork
yeah other than that i will eat anything
um everything is
is available everything's delicious to
me oh that's awesome and
i i mean do you
activism the burn out is real and i saw
you around the election posting a lot of
videos just sort of like
encouraging people to take breaks when
they can is that something
that you've learned more this year
especially
i have learned that mostly over the last
three and a half years the most i mean
i've organized for the last 20 years
and last four years i felt like i
organized for 40 years and four years um
so there were
where you know i suffered very very
extreme anxiety
you know things were like i felt like
the world was swirling around me and one
day i was like wait a minute i gotta get
myself together and it really were
simple things like
remembering to eat drinking water you
know
taking those breaks i hadn't went on
vacation for like
12 years before that and so in 2018 i
went on a vacation
and then i was like well this is great
and then i went on another vacation
like eight months later and then i
wanted another one and i'm very grateful
because there are people graced in this
world who have supported me that way i
mean
people like us as organizers people
think that we're like raking in the
dough and unfortunately
one of the things that i always think
about you know is like i work in a field
that doesn't have retirement plans you
know i don't have
okay you know things like that so people
around me in my community know that and
so what they do is like they'll support
me like okay you want to go on vacation
i'm going to
send you on a vacation i'm with a friend
something like that so i've been very
fortunate to have people look out for my
own well-being as well but their burnout
is real
it's a lot and people have told me this
look
they're like injustice is going to be
here tomorrow so like
that because you are not doing a work
for one day that somehow like the
world's just going to end it's going to
be right
they'll come back i learned that it's
hard but i learned it
no that's important because i it's funny
that you say that
people think that you guys get paid like
big bucks i i would assume the opposite
and also that like you
you technically your work day is could
be 24 hours a day if you
let it it seems like it's the kind of
job like you said and justice is always
there and so there's always time to work
to your point earlier about some of the
kind of social media activism i mean
i've had
a lot of privilege i mean i mean i was
on the cover of glamour magazine you
know i was a
times 100 person of the year you know
things like that yeah people
see those things they assume that
because of that kind of notoriety or
because you're on the front page of
magazine like
aiming to be on the front page right
yeah yeah yeah they might have given you
lunch on your shoot day
but a nice shirt and pants
and then i had to give the shirt hands
back after i wore them yes you know
you know a lot of times you know
particularly for some of us who are more
high-profile activists you know we got
we get
opportunities um and that people make
assumptions about so i want to
kind of clear the record that you know i
feel grateful for
where i am i'm definitely not you know
living in poverty for sure i just don't
want to make sure people know that but
we also do
are in a place where you know we as you
said are committed to this this is our
lifestyle it's not just a job we don't
go nine to five you know sometimes like
i went to i lived in louisville
almost three months away from my family
um i'm going to georgia
the monday after thanksgiving for the
whole month of december
up until january 5th i mean these are
the types of sacrifices that many women
that you'll see in our movements make
every day
um and they're really their families
have to make i mean it's not just us i
mean our families have to
sacrifice the time with us and for us
being around them so i just wanted to
you know shout out those women to say
that you know i see them i'm sure you
see them grace
and that we appreciate what they do for
us and the sacrifices that they make and
hopefully one day the best that we could
do is that history will remember them
and the work that they've done
absolutely okay we're going to take one
last break when we get back i have a
bunch of questions uh from instagram for
you so we're right back with more not
too deep
[Music]
hi friends grace helbig here from the
podcast not too deep which you are
currently listening to
hosted by me grace helbig just wanted to
say a couple of things
one thank you so much for listening and
two
if you are enjoying yourself to such a
degree that you'd love to leave
us a um review on the apple store
that would be so appreciated because
again you are very appreciated for
giving us your time your ears your
attention
whatever it may be uh and that was my
couple of things
now back to me me
i'm i'm gonna get into some internet
questions and i have two questions asked
every single guest that is
on the podcast but before we do that
can you speak to the importance for
people that don't know of these georgia
runoff
elections that are happening because i
didn't know that this was something that
could happen and i'm still learning
every day exactly what's going on and
how to direct attention down there
so any insight you have would be great
absolutely so
georgia has every state has different
ways that they work on their elections
so in georgia when you run in a general
election if none of the two people
running
get 50 or more there's something they
call a runoff
so in georgia both the two senate seats
did not neither candidate got
50 of the of the threshold so they
both went to a runoff which is on
january 5th uh
and january 5th you're going to have two
u.s senate seats that are up in georgia
and there are wonderful people that are
running like um the reverend
raphael warnock who was the pastor of
martin luther king's church the ebenezer
baptist church and he's an organizer
very beloved man
and then there's john ossoff whom many
people know had ran for congress before
you know young
you know um energetic i would call i
wouldn't call him necessarily
you know he's like a progressive center
candidate but it
makes georgia you know yeah anyway so
there's a runoff that's happening on
january 5th and right now the democrats
only have 48
democrats in the in this in the us
senate so we get those two
it would make the democrats have 50. so
it would be 50 50.
and then deciding vote would be kamala
harris because that's how it works the
the vice president becomes a tiebreaker
and so that's why this is so important
because it's one thing to have biden in
the white house and it's another thing
to not have
a democratic majority senate which could
even help move any legislation forward
so what they'll do is as they as
republicans have done done in the past
to president obama is that they block
legislation because the white house is
not their party and i hate that it's
partisan but that's just how it works
so going to georgia and supporting and
uplifting the work that's already
happening in georgia to register more
voters um you know the voter
registration deadline is december 7th
december 14th is when early voting
starts in georgia and then january 5th
is the actual runoff so we really really
need those two senate seats it would be
really
historic if we won those seats out of
georgia it would be incredible
encourage everyone uh to get out
register the vote and also if you are
17 turning 18 i've heard in january that
you can register to vote
as well um which is important so okay
now on to some really hard hitting
questions i'm going to ask you the two
questions ask every single guest that's
on the podcast
the first is who alive or dead would you
most like to throw cold spaghetti at
oh well i have reded cold probably woody
giuliani
ah yeah yeah big time yeah
okay i would ask why but i feel like i
can
uh i can guess just that's all
okay the other question asks every
single guest is to tell us your worst
pant [ __ ] story
or like a bathroom close call scenario
but you can only use three words or
three small phrases
so for example mine is college
jogging front lawn
oh lord yeah a really a really
hard-hitting question for you
um
[Music]
gowanus bridge or the undergroundness
mom okay yeah that paints a picture
that sounds uh nothing good happens
under bridges
i don't think okay let's get into these
questions from instagram
um okay first question how can allies
show up or help the muslim community
with islamophobia
it's a very complex question i'm sure oh
i appreciate that um
question all the time i just say to
people this most simplest thing that we
could do is to just not be bystanders if
you're ever like at a grocery store or
you happen to be in a place where you
see someone
being you know mean to someone who's
muslim or looks muslim you know being
able to say hey that's not okay because
i think a lot of times
muslim women will tell you in particular
that there will be people around and
people just don't intervene or at least
try to
be supportive or just you know being
able like this
like that mom did you know the mom in
the park like yeah the lady didn't know
who i was
um i don't know if she knows any muslims
all i know is that she bought her little
white daughter a book that was about
muslim women and the
girl was so proud to come show it to me
so i know now for sure that that little
girl is never gonna grow up to be like i
hate muslims like yeah
so if you could you know get your kids
to you know watch
shows about muslims which there are um
you know if you
reading books children's books there are
many of both for
children and for uh you know like tweens
i'm actually um
next year i'll have a book coming out uh
that is um
directed towards uh like 10 to 13 year
olds and it's called we're in this
together and it's about cool
you know super hero activist kind of
situation that says
you know has very serious conversations
and then the year after that i'll have a
children's book that's a picture book
for the more younger generation around
like muslims
i mean really more it's like muslims
that's awesome yeah because it truly
does i mean the best thing you can do is
start
young just by exposing like you've done
your children to
the world into things that are outside
of what's directly in their family unit
um okay someone wants to know how do you
handle
personal attacks either on your
character your family your faith
etc um i feel like i'm an expert in that
now
yeah i imagine that you've had so many
years especially now with social media
it's coming from all directions
um i if people will notice how like i do
my social media i don't really engage
people who are vitriolic but i do
age people who ask me hard questions and
one of the things i want to say to
people all the time is that
i'm not a perfect person i'm a flawed
human being um and they're
and again you're gonna disagree with me
on issues and guess what
folks it's fine and i want to disagree
with you and we can have that
conversation
but really you know i focus on my
support network i have a very very
close group of friends i have a very my
family is extremely supportive of the
work that i do
i have a community that loves me and
stands behind me and so i don't really
let it get it to me i don't let it over
consume me and in fact i
me people laugh at me all the time i
make excuses for people all the time i'm
like these people are hurt they're
traumatized they're taking
um they're taking their anger out on me
i i represent something for them
that is not really about me as a person
so i don't just take i don't take social
media personally and i say to people
please do not take social media
personally like how can someone that i
do not know
have any impact on me i don't know you
you've never sat with me and i've had a
conversation with me so
i just don't i mean it took me a while
but i got to the point where i don't
take it personally at all
yeah it's a it seems like a muscle that
you have to constantly kind of
work and exercise a little bit because
there is
so much projection that happens on the
internet and it's
truly wild and being able to kind of
identify that
and separate or distance or create space
between that
i think is huge yeah you know it's
protect you know the one thing
about it has been just the part about my
kids like
being able to have those hard
conversations with them and also there
were times and you know unfortunately
and even in you know kind of recent
times where like
people like docs me put my like home
address on online
you know i've had people mail stuff to
my house you know death threats you know
law enforcement getting involved you
know your kids are like why are the cops
here why is the fbi
house and things like that but again you
know one of the things that i tell my
kids if because it's important to teach
your kids histories i've
had to share with them stories about
like malcolm x and about dr martin
luther king and
fbi like this is all part of the thing
that i'm doing like it's not nothing
about me there's nothing special about
me it's unfortunately part of a history
of what happens to people who
you know are organizers and speak truth
and speak things that make people feel
uncomfortable
yeah uh this question you kind of
touched on but
i want to kind of elaborate a little bit
more someone asked what does it take to
be a good activist
and i kind of want to expand that to
what does it take or what sort of
activism can and should be happening now
that we have voted
biden into office because i think a lot
of people might think great we did it
work's done let's close up for the day
but what can you say about
what you hope continues to happen moving
forward
i mean the best activist is a humble
activist um someone that does not
believe that they're saving the world
you know i don't believe that i can save
the world but i do believe that i can
help alleviate some suffering some harm
that is happening especially to the
people that are in my closest community
uh for me what i say to people all the
time even when the trump administration
took office i said listen like folks
like i don't know how you all got so mad
at trump like
trump didn't introduce me to racism and
he didn't introduce to me to sexism or
misogyny or homophobia or transphobia or
islamophobia or anti-semitism ableism
all the
kind of ills of society like he didn't
that wasn't the first time i learned
about these things and so for us you
know our organizing was before donald
trump and it's going to be after donald
trump
and even with this next administration i
tell people all the time like
unless i'm missing something racism is
still here we still have unarmed black
people who are being
murdered by police around the country we
still have immigrants who are literally
live in fear every day because they
think that they're going to be separated
from their families
there are still women in states across
america who are fighting for their
reproductive rights
hoping that we're not taken back 50
years you know there are
that we still have over 100 million
americans who experience some sort of
poverty
we have 200 over 250 000 people in our
country died of colbit like
these things are still here you know so
with this next administration i actually
expect a lot more from them i
i don't i don't actually feel like the
job is done i feel like our job is still
beginning
so what i hope people do is now we're
going to go from the defensive
to the offensive and now i'm going to
say to joe biden and kamala harris you
know congratulations
you are now the leader of our nation
navs get to work here's the things
and so for me actually i think our being
in the street is going to be much more
productive
under the abident administration than it
was under trump because to be honest
grace nothing changed i was marching
every day
under trump nothing changed
we did not move this administration
anywhere to anywhere they were
right where they wanted to be and stayed
there but i do believe
with biden and and harris that we could
actually move them to a better place
yeah i think it's uh i saw someone
posting something about the mind shift
of holding them accountable to the
promises that they've
made throughout this election season and
making sure that you stay on top of them
because talk is cheap until there's
actual action behind it that's right 100
um this is an important question someone
asked do you like cheese whiz
listen i was tell i was telling somebody
the other day um that
this is really such a mean thing to say
but i was like i don't trust vegans
because i love
cheese yeah yeah yeah yeah i'm a little
bougie grace about my cheese like
oh we've heard that you are foodie and
that's okay if you're going to be
particular
about anything i'm a lady you know i
like my my like fresh mozzarella i live
in bay ridge
so i live around a lot of italians so
yeah people have access to fresh
mozzarella and
ease and feta i'm very bougie with my
cheese so no cheese whiz for me
oh i get it okay uh last question before
we wrap
up what's uh at the top of your bucket
list
uh what's it generally what's coming up
we've heard some of these new book ideas
that will be
springing up in the future are there
other things on the horizon that you're
working on
you know um i'm part of a group as you
know called until freedom um so
beginning our work we're actually going
to go back to louisville around the
brianna taylor case uh
and but for real you know my next thing
on my bucket list that i want to work on
is i think that my memoir has the
potential to be
like a very mini series and get people
to see these things in a
in a more visual way so i'm going to be
uh working with some folks on trying
that a reality that's so and i think i i
read somewhere that there's going to be
a like youth friendly version of the
memoir coming out
is that true yeah so there's going to be
the what they call the young adult
version that comes out next year and
then the year after that there will be a
picture book based on the book as well
oh that's awesome you have so many great
things going on
um linda before we wrap up we like to
give our guests a
a little token of our appreciation from
upstate we have a
digital personalized fortune cookie that
i believe melissa has emailed
to you potentially and you are welcome
to read it aloud to the class
trump threatened to leave the united
states if it's confirmed he will not
have a second term this opens up doors
to a new kind of travel ban
as in one that wouldn't let him back in
the stars may be in your favor
who knows who knows it's out there
linda this is so wonderful thank you for
such a great conversation
where can people find you can find um
empower change
until freedom all and your book if they
don't already know
my book you can find it it's called we
are not here to be bystanders um you can
find it where any books are sold um it's
also i have the audiobook version as
well
um and you can find me on all social
media platforms with my real name so
it's linda sarsour
um and they're all verified so if it's
not verified it hate me and you could
follow until freedom at until freedom
everywhere so until freedom facebook
until freedom twitter instagram and
empower change
again based just our with the letter m
power change and power change i love it
thank you
so much this was so great and make sure
guys you go check out everything that
she's up to
and everything that she will be up to
and make sure you're registered to vote
if you live in georgia and get ready to
vote in january
yeah we'll see you guys next time
another episode of not too deep goodbye
too deep too deep too deep not too deep
with christ not too deep is a production
of grace helbig incorporated producer
melissa d
montz edited by shireen lani eunis post
production sound by chris henry and
an extra special thanks to flula for the
theme music